want to give too much of it away because
I really want people to watch it because
I mean I've talked about cocaine Cowboys
probably a hundred times in this podcast
it's one of my all-time favorite pocket
excuse me all time favorite
documentaries but this is this is a
story that almost writes itself
it's so bonkers the and the fact that it
all could have been avoided if one guy
just paid another guy or just didn't try
to rip him off I like for grants yeah
like nothing doesn't make any sense it's
fucking crazy and the guy what a bizarro
personality he was who would just tan
every day and hang out at this doctor's
office in the waiting room telling
everybody how great it was like the
whole thing is so strange
like that's everybody remembers it is
like the a rod or a roid scandal you
know and the truth of the matter is that
Alex Rodriguez was collateral damage yes
in this whole thing yeah it was not
about him don't tell Alex that but it's
not about him you know it's it it was
really the highest the career of the
highest paid baseball player of all time
effectively ended over a four thousand
dollar debt between this cocaine
addicted fake doctor and his faked an
addicted steroid patient and it's like
that's why I said it's like a Florida
fuckery story straight up it's just like
this is classic only in Miami absurd
farce and that's what you specialize in
specialize in Florida fuckery I go to
your Twitter feed all the time for
current Florida fucker it's just it's
yet distilled it's just like it's pure
Florida fuckery yeah it's just it's and
that's what this story is to me it's
like Miami is just well I say the great
thing about Miami is it's so close to
the United States but like it's it's
also like it's America's Casablanca
mm-hmm like just people kind of flee to
Miami from like all over the country and
all over the world usually leaving some
kind of criminality in their wake yeah
and you know come here and kind of there
and reinvent themselves you know like
it's just and then you have all of these
criminals there who then kind of baking
in the Sun you know in this kind of
multicultural fucking paia
you know that we have and then they just
like and then they start putting their
their minds together and brainstorming
and they hatch just the most inane
schemes and scams like that's our
primary export from Miami is just
schemes and scams well it's just so
amazing that it's still a cocaine
culture - after all these years it still
has a giant cocaine engine pumping out
all this chaos we don't have any
indigenous industry I mean there's no
factory where everybody goes to work and
then 30 years later gets a watch there's
no there's no business there it's Carl
Hiaasen says all we produce in Florida
is oranges and machine guns you know we
don't make anything that we sell the
dream we sell the sunshine
you know it's lies that came true yeah
you know and so and even more
frightening is the Miami of today is the
America of tomorrow so it's like there's
a lot of lessons to be gleaned from down
there but it's basically at this point
of money a real estate hustle and a
money-laundering capital so it's really
no different than it ever was everybody
likes to tell me how it's changed it's
grown I'm like just because you've built
a bunch of shit doesn't mean we've grown
right and Miami is just like Miami is
one of the youngest cities in the
country in your parlance so it'd be
about one person old or one and a half
people ago like one and a half people
ago you know where the were one of the
youngest cities um barely a hundred just
over a hundred you know correct me if
I'm wrong because I've said this before
but isn't there more banks per capita in
Miami than anywhere else
well it certainly there certainly was
before the you know the the the Great
Recession when a lot of them started
shutting down but most of them have
rebounded one of the cleverer things
some of the real estate developers did
was they opened their own bank literally
their own Bank they had a bank where the
entire board of the bank were all real
estate developers and over 90 percent of
the loans the bank made was insider
loans just to the board and then of
course they went belly-up in the great
recession and what happened we bailed
him out so it was all their own so yeah
it's great
held out real estate salesman real
estate who loaned themselves money that
is round up being backed ultimately by
us by the taxpayer ah yeah I mean that's
the old remember they I mean you hear
that line all the time now that like you
know
the people used to rob the bank from the
outside in now it's yeah now it's from
the inside out but no none could be
truer than that story and that's a Miami
story and when the Great Recession
happened
the FDIC had to open an office in
Florida because we had more bank
closures than any other state in the
Union because we were like you could go
down there I mean you could buy a
fucking mortgage for your dog at a
drive-through in Miami in the in like
the the late 90s early oz and I remember
interviewing a guy we were doing working
on a project called Ponzi state about
the state of Florida as like a case
study in the Great Recession years ago
we never finished it unfortunately but
we're interviewing this guy and he says
um you know we were this is pre like big
short like this before anybody sort of
knew a lot about this and he said we
were down here in Miami setting fires
and Wall Street was trying to read our
smoke signals that's why I say like the
Miami of today is the America of
tomorrow
sure it is every time I go there I
always go
I forgot how fucking crazy this place is
if you really should have to have a
passport
it's I love it I really do love it's a
crazy place to do stand-up you know I
did this job because I was doing a
Netflix special and I was doing it a
couple months after I did this gig in
Miami and so I was using those Yonder
bags you know what those are where
people have to put their cell phone and
yes this magnetic bag you keep the phone
but you hold the phone in the book if
you want to use it you just have to step
outside they open up the bag and they
give your phone in every other City it
made for a better show because people
just sat down and watch the show in
Miami it made for literally 40 percent
of the crowd at any given time was
getting up and going to the back and
using their phone and coming back in
they were just constantly moving around
and presumed what was to use their phone
they might be a bit powdering their
noses they might have been but it was
they you know that was because I had
done gigs before that where they didn't
have the Yonder bags and this wasn't the
problem
but at Miami just everybody needed to
use their phone so they just kept
getting up and coming back and it was
just chaos well it's also a selfish town
like it's it's basically a town a town
of assholes and really and and so like I
always say the I mean it reflects in
everything that we do in the way
we behaved certainly in the way that we
drive like believe it or not like people
are so much more chill and calm here
in traffic in LA I swear to God and LA
was famous for like road rage like yeah
la like created invented road rage but
like Miami it's such a crazy angry weird
place cuz it's like when push comes to
shove we're in Miami chill the fuck out
like it's all good it's a beautiful
place like and it's a shared experience
the traffic sucks for all of us just
chill out use your turn signal for
crying out loud and just but that's why
they I say that's why they call it Miami
Sun our a me or your a me it's my
fucking a me and stay out of my fucking
a me it's just I don't seem to love it
you seem to thrive yeah I can't really
function anywhere else doesn't make any
sense it's and it's so frustrating to I
was you know I'm I'm a native Floridian
and a lifelong Miami and I for a while I
was I was pretty determined to like
leave behind a better Florida than the
one I was so inexorably connected to
cocaine one of my best friend Steve
Graham was an ophthalmologist he did his
residency in Miami so he did his
residency in emergency rooms in Miami
and he was there in the 80s during like
the height basically during when cocaine
Cowboys takes place and he saw
everything just he mean he had all these
pictures of bullet holes and skull
fragments and people with light bulbs
stuffed up their asses and just he said
every day was just fuckin chaos we know
Miami idea everywhere else the light
bulb goes off over your head in Miami we
should shove it right up our asses he
said they had to pull a light bulb out
of a guy's ass one of those ones that
look like a Christmas tree those curly
ones this guy stuck a light bulb up his
ass and it broke in his ass at least he
was concerned about the environment
that's like one of those environmentally
like sound like no environmentally sound
like yeah they were just thicker glass
like it felt like he could get it in his
ass better
like though that was the area to cut
your teeth if you were a cop or a lawyer
or a journalist or an ER doctor I
remember talking to any ER doctor once
he tells me a story 1980 shortly after
the Mariel boatlift started which I
think everybody's kind of pop-culture
frame of reference for the Mariel
boatlift is Scarface Tony Montana was a
marielito that's at the beginning of the
movie when you know Castro was ranting
and raving that he's flushing the
toilets of Cuba on to the United States
specifically to Miami and so he was
working at the the trauma center at
Jackson Memorial our emergency room in
Miami and he said he got a Mariel
refugee these guys would stand on the
beach they would it looked like Havana
in South Beach you know like there's
that like coral seawall and it just like
it had a really have an of I've so they
would go they would chill mostly at
these flop houses south of 5th Street in
Miami Beach where like the cops would
literally just they would be leaving
after a stabbing at one of these places
and they'd be three blocks away they'd
get a call to go back because now there
was a shooting or something else it
would be going there with like a all
around the clock and so and they would
just get in gunfights like literally
would just be like they someone would
cheated Domino's and they would just
pull out a gun and one guy would shoot
the other guy and so he has a Mariel
refugee who comes in to the emergency
room with a gunshot wound any news
Spanish he was bilingual he said to the
guys you're really lucky because if this
bullet had hit you know a few
centimeters or whatever this way you
would have died immediately you would
have bled out right there on the scene
died instantly and guys splits a few
days later another Mariel refugee comes
in with a gunshot wound in exactly the
same spot where he had told the other
guy that if he got hit there he would
have died could never prove it never was
able to trace it back but he was pretty
well convinced that it was a revenge
shooting for the other shooting and the
guy knew exactly where to shoot him and
kill him because the doctor had told him
where to do that but that was like
everyday Miami the lady who cuts my hair
for Christ's sake
she said Billy I was so naive in those
days you know you you should I cut
peoples hair you know they come over
kiss her goodbye and put a tip in her in
her pocket you know and she'd go home
turn her pockets
inside out have our little crumbled
bills and everything and one day she
finds a little baggie of white powder
that's something that one of her clients
had slipped into her pocket as a tip and
she said to her girlfriend she's what
what the hell is this and her friend
said oh shit that's worth more than gold
that's the best tip you got you got all
day
that little baggie that was just like
the culture and it's and it's I mean
it's not that is that anywhere else I
can imagine that in like Nebraska
someone tipping you and cocaine people
would be like what what the fuck are you
doing
listen it's just like like I said say
America's Casablanca it's just no place
like it it's such a strange place yeah
everybody everything is for sale
still nothing you know and like I said
we are about a person old that's how far
back Miami goes I was watching a video
about the culture of renting super cars
to people so they can pretend that it's
their car huge in Miami yeah yeah we got
all these Brickell brick' least a
thousand airs you know driving their
rented fucking Lambos yeah you know and
blowing the engines out on South Beach
because they don't know how to drive
them just getting towed down the street
it's just listen it's a fake it till you
make it kind of town and there's nothing
really to make there you can't really
other than a real estate hustle money
laundering drugs politics being a crop
politician there's really no other way
to make it it's not a real industry no
not at all there's a lot of professional
fighters come out of Miami about that
whole area Coconut Grove and a lot of
aggression a lot of poverty it's a it's
a third-world economy down there the
disparity between the haves and
have-nots the income gap is widest and
getting wider in miami-dade County than
just about any city in the country or
any metropolitan area in the country Wow
so and that's why I said that Miami of
today is the America of tomorrow if you
want to know what challenges will face
as a nation or calamities will befall us
in the years to come you need only look
at at Miami tioman called it the canary
in the coalmine the bellwether and so
you know when the election was playing
out the cycle in 2016 I was like you
know all my friends are just like this
can this Trump thing can't happen I was
like hang on I'll say Florida elected
and in fact re-elected Rick Scott to be
governor he is the biggest Medicare
fraud stir in the history of the United
States everybody knows it everybody's
aware of it very well publicized we've
weary elected him okay we elected him
twice as the top fucking executive in
our state like what makes you think that
the United States of America wouldn't do
that and I know it's fair to say like
you know if you're gonna be the governor
of the state you should know a little
something about the largest industry in
the state like you were gonna be the
governor of Michigan you should have
some familiarity with the automobile
industry and manufacturing and in
Florida if you're gonna be the governor
arguably you should know something about
our biggest industry which is Medicare
fraud basically I mean you could argue
that he's the most qualified man for the
job
oh yeah we had like Medicare fraud as is
one of the largest industries has been
for decades I mean we have billions and
billions of dollars in fraud that just
so they run it so you'll go into like
Little Havana or Hialeah for example in
a municipality and in miami-dade and
there'll be a little Lalita sitting
behind a desk half-asleep and she'll be
surrounded in this tiny little one-room
office by little mailboxes you know like
peel boxes and a mailman comes in every
day and just puts checks in the boxes
and they're like some cases they've
stolen Social Security numbers and and
you know uh stolen identities basically
and some cases they're just old people
who aren't aware that their mail is
being forwarded to this location and
they've just got they I think Miami for
a while we had more Medicare payments
for HIV and AIDS medication then every
other part of the country combined and
it's all just old people so it's like
you would have to assume that a hundred
percent of our elderly population
suffered from HIV said hm we're HIV
positive possible you had female
patients getting penis pumps that were
paid for by even know that Medicare
covered that
I gotta look into that but uh you know
that was a thing well thanks Obama
but you watch the oxycontin Express see
now but that's all about how they would
have the pain management centers and
they were connected to the pharmacies
you'd go to the doctor hey my back hurts
you know what you need this go right
next door and you just get right all
they would prescribe was oxys and
sometimes it wasn't even next door
sometimes it was like go to that window
yeah right next door they say show the
doctor your x-ray yeah you have to get
your x-ray done somewhere else cuz they
weren't doing it so in hand the doctor
your x-ray he look at it go oh shit it
was upside down he wouldn't do it he's
gonna be like oh yeah oh shit you know
what you need go to that window over
there and fill this prescription and we
had more pill mills they called them in
Broward County which is the county just
north of miami-dade then we had
McDonald's locations and there was
literally like the Appalachian Trail
they were coming down they were stocking
up on oxy and we were fueling a death
epidemic like in Kentucky but they were
moving over more cars with Florida
plates than in state plates up there
because Floridians were like well shit
we can't let them have all the action
we'll drive up and we'll export the shit
and at the peak of the pill mill
epidemic the oxy epidemic in Florida
seven people a day were dying and women
and children and and we subsist from
hustle to hustle what you wonder why
didn't the government crackdown on that
shit widens our regulated well first our
governor and we did we deal with this in
screwball is the biggest Medicare fraud
stir in the history of the country so he
wasn't exactly shall we say vigilant or
interested in cracking down on medical
related get away with a magic mark Maya
magic I guess I mean he listened he he
got he pled the fifth amendment like 75
times in a videotaped deposition that
was used in a campaign ad against him
and Florida was like we're good we're
good with that up and he just listened
white rich men kind of walked between
the raindrops in this country